hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for my June 50 2020 what's going on how
how's it going on this stupid [ __ ]
thing beeping I don't know how to shut
it off you know when I when I smashed my
[ __ ] cell phone between my car door
and I had sweatpants with shallow
pockets shallow like me right
fell out and I closed the door so the
cell phone I keep hitting you I keep it
in [ __ ] Mia I'm sorry this [ __ ]
thing so I had to set it up on my
[ __ ] goddamn computer and I can't get
it to stop now I'm literally like force
let's see force quit force quit
messenger messages force quit forcing
quitting all right there so I did that
now I'm gonna turn the volume back on it
you watch this thing it's still gonna
[ __ ] beep anyway continuing
continuing [ __ ] time
I'm literally watching the 1952 World
Series Brooklyn Dodgers first in New
York Yankees know it know it full well
that the New York Yankees win even if I
didn't it says World Series game 7
Yankees win fourth straight title
October 7th 1952 in the bottom of the
screen why would you do that MLB Network
you know I had the option of not looking
it up I mean I knew that they were gonna
win it because I knew Brooklyn didn't
win until 1955 I mean I'm enough of a
sports geek don't know that the Brooklyn
Dodgers would known as dub bombs because
they would always [ __ ] lose the World
Series in fact they lost four World
Series in seven years all to the New
York Yankees I believe well I looked
that up didn't I had that somewhere here
mm-hmm yes they lost it as a nice play
at first to get Mickey Mantle Mickey
Mantle 20 years old at this point just
taken over for Jody and they called him
a Mel Allen's doing the game and he's
the guy comes up to the plate batting
left-handed hits a home run two innings
later comes up hits a base hit to drive
in a run and they key called a
magnificent Mickey the twenty-year-old
nobody knew nobody knew what this kid
was gonna be so anyway they lost to the
Yankees in 1947 in seven games they lost
in five games in 49 they lost in seven
games
in 52 and they lost in six games in 53
and at that point people were like well
they're never gonna [ __ ] beat him and
then in 1955 Giants wanted 54 beat the
Cleveland Indians and in 54 they beat
him they beat the Yankees in seven games
unbelievable so Brooklyn got their
championship and then unfortunately the
Dodgers left I think in 57 or 58 59 but
Los Angeles Dodgers won the World Series
and in 63 and in 65 and all those titles
would have been in Brooklyn that would
have been so cool if they still had the
three teams there well you had the
Brooklyn Dodgers the New York Giants
playing in the Polo Grounds BAM look do
I hit force [ __ ] quit dude I don't
know what I'm beside myself I just hit
force [ __ ] quit I can't force quit
out of messenger now it doesn't even
show up I'm taking this I'm taking this
[ __ ] app and I'm dragging it over to
the [ __ ] trash once I get all my
numbers back that's what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna do I got most of my numbers back
but what I'm doing is I'm putting in
them into my computer as I get up that
that that that that's what I'm doing
so anyway I'm watching this game seven
1952 World Series okay the Red Sox have
broken the curse
you know we went what do we run we've
won
one two three four we want four right
buried the curse we're back right we're
doing what we do every century we went
five in the early part we're in four or
five earlier them and then we take it
easy take it easy
you know you don't be funny because a
lot of people this wouldn't be funny as
a Red Sox fan but I won't be it I won't
be around to see it for the rest of the
century although I plan on making the
70s again I'll be a hundred and one
years old in 2070 anyway one of the
major reasons they tried to say that the
Red Sox didn't win it they had all these
[ __ ] things they were cursed all that
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] and then there was
the real reasons okay the ballpark the
way the ballpark was built and how we
would always try to oh my god if we get
a power hitter [ __ ] right-handed
hitter he's gonna hit 90 home runs never
happened they just [ __ ] pitched him
low and inside he ground into a double
play every [ __ ] time to end the
inning and but the major reason why was
aside from Beck we just weren't a good
organization in the Yankees were a
phenomenal organization was we also were
the last team to integrate so what I'm
thinking what would be wild can you
imagine if that repeated itself this
century with the Red Sox won four or
five before 1920
we won five last century this year this
century we've won four now what if
robots gets so lifelike and then they
have rights you know and they're
protesting and like you know we should
be allowed to play in sports too right
and then everybody debating but then the
human element is gone I mean a robot
doesn't give a [ __ ] about you know that
it's game seven he's just he's a [ __ ]
robot and then people will be like well
you know we the Nerds would be like well
we actually did planes we we put in a
motion program and we run them a little
higher emotion during a game seven or
whatever but what if like say it goes
that way and the Red Sox end up being
the last
team to integrate robots and then dance
Shaughnessy's great-grandson ends up
writing curse
cursive I don't know whatever the
[ __ ] curse of the Dave or something
like that whatever whatever you call the
[ __ ] robot I'm sorry
so anyway it's like 42 Casey Stengel
slapping his [ __ ] arms flipping out
how bad these this would I love watching
how similar the game still is and who
knew they had split screen technology
back then they'd have a runner on first
and Mel Allen was explaining we're gonna
go to the dual screen here and the
quality the picture is so poor it almost
looks like the guy on first is standing
next to the batter like the wise why is
that guy in the on-deck circle that
close what if he fouls one off and why
isn't he holding up bad so what do you
what do you want for me people what do
you want me to do do you want me to
watch the news and watch that [ __ ]
overt [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] that's racist
dumb [ __ ] what do you what is the
[ __ ] wrong with that guy it's gonna
have a rally in Tulsa Oklahoma like you
know I don't know I just you know with
it with any with any luck the guy just
slips on a banana peel you know I don't
know wish death on anybody he slips on a
banana peel and then it's just basically
whatever is second in command guy is
versus the the other guy they're the
boring guy you know and we just kind of
get past this guy because I'm gonna
handle conservative I can handle liberal
thought I can handle both of them to a
[ __ ] point but you can't have a
[ __ ] I mean you will be well people
still vote him in like he's proud of
what happened in Tulsa you know I mean
how much do you love your [ __ ] money
that you're yet you're able to [ __ ]
sleep at night [ __ ] you know and you
know it's literally it's like watching
sports just like me sitting here they
already have the title the flag has been
flying over there for almost sixty eight
[ __ ] years and I'm still rooting
against them
anyway but we saw the [ __ ] that the
Brooklyn Dodgers had the bases loaded
with one out and Duke Snider their
Mickey Mantle their mail their Willie
Mays up to the plate and he ended up
popping out to third which reminded me
of when Carl Yastrzemski and that one
game playoff popped out to nettles on
third but they still had bases loaded
you know now they needed a hit and then
the next guy came up was Jackie Robinson
and he hit a pop fly it's actually a
famous play I believe because I remember
seeing footage of it before he hit a pop
fly in the infield and Billy Martin was
on second base the great Billy Martin
the great characters players managers
ever in the history of the game
he got underneath it and it just the
wind caught it and started blowing it in
and it's a famous catch where he races
in his hat flies off and he just they
just got it done they did what needed
Pee Wee Reese going D why do I care
that's it that's it oh [ __ ] let me
listen to Mel Allen I love sports
history though
you want to hear the final call you want
to hear in an area affected by butter
butter butter pie
how about that 42
you can't believe the quality of this
game look at this now they're going
right to the Pirates Orioles in the
1960s this are early 70s this might be
Roberto Clemente's yeah I think that was
the night that was the one that they won
in the early 70s with a young Willie
Stargell and I want to say that that was
the last game Clemente played or day
Clemente get his three Hut
last game regular season and then
unfortunately died in a plane crash I
don't remember I don't remember this is
what I'm doing people I'm back I'm back
to not watching the news I am I am
hardcore into just watching [ __ ] that
already happened and right today I'm
watching a bunch of World Series games
well my my beautiful baby boy sleeps and
while the [ __ ] ballparks have changed
so much I don't even know what this this
is but world series come on man
Baltimore Orioles first the Pittsburgh
Pirates they met once in 79 and once in
the early 70s I forget what I want to
say this was 71 72 or 73 and this looks
like old War Memorial Stadium in
Baltimore looking at the the uniforms
anyway yeah that's what the hell I've
been doing I just got so into that game
from 1952 I actually started yelling at
Billy Cox the third baseman for the
Brooklyn Dodgers he made an error it
didn't cost him anything because they
didn't score a run or anything and then
he had another one get by him but
what's-his-face Pee Wee Reese backed him
up once again saving a run and then he
made a great play oh this is 71 1971
this is going on all right I'm be a
little distracted
here I didn't know Ralph Houk I forgot
he played for the Yankees he was a coach
he's a manager for them
and then became a you know manager for
the Red Sox and when I think I think
went back to the Yankees I can't
remember but uh was fun to watch and
also just the way they shot the game
where you were not behind the pitcher it
was like they kind of shot it from where
the broadcasters sat so you couldn't
really see signs or anything like that I
think once they started going behind the
the pitcher that's when like you know
you got a TV in the [ __ ] in the
locker room you got some little kid
looking down this deal in science I mean
all of this [ __ ] all this [ __ ] that
the Astros are getting [ __ ] for I mean
people have been doing that for [ __ ]
ever they just weren't dumb enough to be
oh no I still can't believe that the I'm
supposed to believe that they were
banging on a [ __ ] trash can that
[ __ ] loud how loud you'd have to bang
on it for nine [ __ ] innings five six
seven game series and no one could
figure that out
well I guess they did figure it out
because they had an investigation about
it I don't know what the [ __ ] do I know
this I'll tell you what I do know f is
for family season four is streaming now
on on Netflix and it's [ __ ] crushing
and everybody's loving it so that's the
best season I'm getting all these great
emails so thank you guys so much for
watching if you hadn't had a chance I
guess you're supposed to still be inside
I don't know what you're supposed to do
I guess everybody's just sort of doing
what the [ __ ] they want to do but if
you're hanging inside please check it
out and watch it one of every year we
seem to add another incredible actor to
the show this year is no different we
have the amazing Jonathan banks who I
first got to meet when I was working on
Breaking Bad way back in the day and the
first time I ever saw Jonathan as an
actor was he played one of the heavies
in Beverly Hills Cop the beginning of
that movie which I don't want to ruin
but uh we used to mean my family's to
always do like his lines
there's Roberto Clemente coming to the
plate we do each other's lines
hey Mikey what'd you get lost we used to
do that all the [ __ ] time somebody
was late for dinner
that was like you know do you guys do
that with you you're in your family have
your own like you got to have your own
inside jokes no built just your family
it was that [ __ ] unique alright
alright relax relax we've all been
quarantine for a while we're all a
little [ __ ] edgy so I'm doing this
Sunday afternoon I am doing Jimmy Kimmel
tomorrow I got a bunch of other [ __ ] I
have to take care of so I'm trying to
knock this thing out here doing another
episode of Bill Bert later on today and
in between I've been watching my
beautiful son you know my daughter's
over my in-laws house oh [ __ ] I'm just
doing a lot of stuff so she comes home
she asked me for to make her a Dutch
baby also known as a German pancake also
known as a right there Fred because if I
eat one of those I immediately I have to
take a [ __ ] nap so I'm gonna make her
one of those when she gets home and
she's amazing my daughter is like I
don't know what happened in the last
month but like she actually grew an inch
and and then like cognitively like the
level of conversation went to a whole
other level
and she was became even more beautiful
and I know I'm all prejudiced here
because I'm a dad but I'm telling you
man just like blew me away you just
sitting there one day and all of a
sudden you're just having a full-on
conversation with this little kid it's
amazing
so I can't wait for her to get home I'm
watching all this baseball we're gonna
go play a little t-ball and all that
[ __ ] so anyways I'm doing Jimmy Kimmel
tomorrow also the king of Staten Island
I've been getting great reviews people
that have been watching it have been
awesome it's 20 bucks to stream and I
know only good 20 bucks well you know
you can have like [ __ ] 10 people
sitting in the room and you know y'all
pay 2 bucks it's a great movie
everybody's really enjoying it I want to
thank everybody that's watched it that
and f is for family I want to thank the
great Joe Rogan for having me on his
podcast to help promote it
and if you haven't seen that I did an
episode that of the Joe Rogan experience
that I think he posted Friday so and I
believe that's the latest one but you
never know with him the hardest-working
man in show business there you might
have done another one since then but uh
and then also Robert Kelley I did that
you know podcast and that's it I got
nothing so now I'm turning off the
[ __ ] TV finally figured out how to
get everybody on the same goddamn page
here so I saw a couple of [ __ ]
hilarious just amazing videos you know
what else am I gonna do people I'm not
gonna lie to you I got nothing I'm just
trying to bang out the first half-hour
this thing before I get the [ __ ]
advertisements and then the questions
and everything from Andrew there was
this [ __ ] guy I don't want to get
anybody in trouble here because it's a
very colorful video all right there's a
guy all right and he's walking by an
establishment you know and he wants to
make fun he's basically doing the video
to show that people are not quarantine
right so he you know cuz he's the smart
guy right so he's trying to on the
[ __ ] you know as the kids say on the
sneak tip belief probably old people
said at this point he's trying to film
him without him knowing so he could be
like oh my god they're so [ __ ] stupid
I'm so smart so he starts filming this
[ __ ] kid saw him and just absolutely
[ __ ] trashed him [ __ ] trashed him
all his friends trashed him and then
they used you know some colorful
language and / not politically correct
language then the dude flips the whole
thing around like he wasn't doing
anything it's like yes you were yes your
work you were trying to be a smarmy [ __ ]
and you got caught and then you got
[ __ ] roasted and now you're trying to
do this thing like you're somehow the
victim 9 I don't condone the language
used in this video but what I didn't
like is that's that classic [ __ ]
horseshit
you [ __ ] created this situation it
was a very [ __ ] chick thing if I can
get misogynistic here all right as
opposed to what Bill you know it's like
you created the [ __ ] situation and
then you didn't get you know you you
initiated this [ __ ] social situation
and then you didn't like how it got how
it ended up you know how it turned out
and then all of a sudden you're the
victim you are not the victim now if you
want to debate the language in it that's
a completely separate thing but the way
the video is posted is my entire [ __ ]
problem with 24 hour news networks right
down the [ __ ] that post videos why
can't why couldn't he just post it
saying like hey I was trying to be a
sneaky [ __ ] and then these guys caught
me and then [ __ ] trashed me
it's incredible video but I'm trying to
you know whatever I'm speaking in
generalities here anyway sorry I'm
reading text message just to see if I
got the the videos here and then I just
watched a bunch of [ __ ] about [ __ ]
animals and stuff you know Brogan's into
that stuff and he got me into and it's
just it's some of the some of the videos
are just too much
so like the praying mantis ones are just
like my god I think God gave reptiles
the [ __ ] brains that they have
because of the awful deaths that they
that they have to [ __ ] deal with and
I notice with mammals that I believe
have a bigger brain right you wouldn't
know that listening to this podcast but
I believe they have a bigger brain so
they at least had the decency to kill
what the [ __ ] they're gonna eat before
they eat it
except for bears and wild dogs wild dogs
basically just you know if it's small
enough it's a rabbit they'll rip it
apart
if it's something bigger they just start
[ __ ] you know I don't know it's it's
it's
you know I like bears I like watch from
scratch their backs and [ __ ] I like them
sitting you know in a pool of water like
they're in a [ __ ] Jacuzzi I like when
you know as I mentioned on Rogue and I
like when they ride the bicycle at the
circus I'm into that [ __ ] I don't like
him when watching him take down like a
[ __ ] elk it's just [ __ ] ripping
meat out of the things back as it things
like bar or I don't know you watch that
[ __ ] but I kind of went down one of
those [ __ ] little rabbit holes and
then yeah I discovered the praying
mantis and I will never look at that
[ __ ] thing the same way again it's
like it's like it went to a Gracie dojo
and it has with like its its front
[ __ ] Vice [ __ ] it's like I don't know
it has you know like those some of those
crazy martial arts weapons you know I
don't know combined with wrestling where
you put like nails on it ship till we
know what a [ __ ] praying mantis looks
like all right all right I'm sorry okay
I don't know what to tell you here
sitting in a loud leather chair I'm
icing my shoulder hoping I didn't have a
[ __ ] setback
I might just bite the bullet just
[ __ ] just do what Rogen's been
telling me to do just go get my [ __ ]
blood spun taking out blood spun and
then they shoot a baby into your
shoulder whatever the [ __ ] it is that
they do then come back right
brand-new shoulders start [ __ ]
bench-pressing again that weird ass [ __ ]
I think I'm gonna do it I don't know why
I consider it like cheating oh dumb am i
modern medicine is cheating I don't know
so I'm also suffering a little bit here
people took the [ __ ] lack of sleep I
gotta tell you my son is is he's now
like really like like a half-hour he was
awake and he was just like looking
around you know and I heard like the
first I don't know how long are their
life it's like an acid trip because
there
looking they have no idea what anything
is you know when you set them down to
change their diaper I read that the
reason why they really start crying is
because they have no sense of gravity
because you're not holding on to him
they feel like they're falling which
made me feel really sad for my boy so
what I do now is I just I kind of leave
my forearm there for him to grab on to
and I want to say he's crying a little
less I don't know if that's like he
least feels like he has a tree branch
but then maybe he's just laying there
like I don't know how much longer I can
hang on but if he has no sense of
gravity then he doesn't know the
ramifications of it how do they how do
they figure that out isn't that a guess
because no one can remember back to then
except for a couple people that work at
carnivals they can't remember you know
they say they meditate you go all the
way back to the womb the woomba is that
any saying that's like that sword is it
sword sward wool wool who knows all
right with that I guess I'm going to I'm
gonna take a break here and read some
advertising even though I don't have any
yet or am I gonna talk to you about
World Series champions let's see what we
got here oh for [ __ ] sakes where did it
go where did it go you know you try to
click on something there it is all right
beautiful maybe I should start watching
the new so I have more to talk about
other than no you know this is this is
your oasis I'm sticking with the
business plan here alright so here's on
the 1950's go let's start 1945 okay this
is the people want tigers candles beat
the [ __ ] Red Sox in 46 Yankees
Indians Yankees Yankees Yankees Yankees
Yankees what the [ __ ] one two three four
five in a row then Giants and Dodgers
then Yankees then Braves then Yankees
then Los Angeles Dodgers then Pirates
then Yankees Yankees 1960 the shot heard
around the world and then that was it
that was the that was the end of the
Golden Age and the Yankees went to the
World Series the next two years in a row
and lost and then they they their streak
was finally broken where they they went
you know Babe Ruth we sold them but
still they were smart enough to buy him
but Lou Gehrig was there so when Ruth
and Gehrig to Joe DiMaggio to Mickey
Mantle and you basically have 40 years
of total [ __ ] domination and then who
was the guy who was who's the big Yankee
in the 60s Bobby Murcer was their big
guy and he was the first like named
Yankee I believe not to get a ring which
was almost unheard of and and also you
know with the expansion of baseball on
that type of stuff
it became harder all of a sudden you
know there's 2014's 25 teams you know
your odds just keep getting bigger and
bigger then they come back in 77 and 78
because the [ __ ] cheap-ass Oakland
Athletics didn't want to pay their team
that won three in a row 72 73 and 74 I
should have known that the Big Red
Machine won in 75 and 76 76 beating the
Yankees four games to none swept our
asses that's what Pete Rose said to me
when I got his autograph I was at the I
was at the mall there and at Caesars and
I bought two pictures I think I told
this story before one was him sliding
into third base headfirst in the 1975
World Series where they beat the Boston
Red Sox right and his helmet had blown
off you know and he was diving in the
air and then the other one was in 1976
almost the identical picture it's him
sliding
third base head face had head first
helmet off so I said to him can you sign
the first one bill I'm sorry because it
was with the Red Sox and he just in he
looked at many goes I'm not I go to I go
you'll get the joke in a second I go I'm
a Red Sox fan I go and then in the
second one can you write Bill you're
welcome and then he laughed and he got I
was like thank God because when he
looked at me as I got [ __ ] Charlie
hustles gonna kick the [ __ ] out of me
here it was so cool I was I was me in
law head and we actually got to talk to
him about hitting and it was funny too
cuz he sort of tested us to see if we
were just a couple of jerk-offs who
wanted to talk to him cuz I go hey who
was the toughest guy you ever faced and
he just looked at his he goes who do you
think I was like I I'm trying to think
the era's he played so I was like Bob
Gibson he's like nope
and then who did law I had guessed
what's his face from the the the Dodgers
which ended up being the right team the
big guy who had the heart attack power
pitcher built like Clemens began with
addy Don Don Drysdale he's like nope
and then we guessed a few more and we go
who we go he said Sandy Koufax we like
really yeah and he imitated the ball
he's just on either side left and right
hand like it was just fallin off the
table
said he was the toughest and that's the
greatest hitter as far as hits he's got
the he has the title so I like doing
that [ __ ] I like going to those not even
just get their autograph because I don't
give a [ __ ] about that cuz I'm gonna end
up losing it anyways there's me in the
back of my closet just actually being
able to ask them that question who was
the toughest guy you ever faced you know
and then you just some jerk-off fan
there's no camera there so they don't
have to worry about anybody trying to do
any [ __ ] got your [ __ ] with them
and they actually my experience has been
they open up and they actually love
talking about it the way I love talking
comedy alright guess
what I got the got the reeds here I got
the reeds so hey I'm gonna take a break
here we're gonna do a little the
advertising and uh let me make see so I
can't [ __ ] Andrew drop this [ __ ]
alright almost 30 minutes and then I'm
gonna come back with the wonder of
editing and I'm gonna read all your
questions here for the week alright I am
back oh we got the coke we got
everything we got the library any of
that [ __ ] do that [ __ ] wonderful hey
everybody it's simply safe what's the
number one sign of a bad home security
system a guy with a bloody axe standing
at the end of your [ __ ] bed it's a
hell of a question what's the number one
sign of a bad home security system a
home security system that's so
complicated that you never use it well
yeah I mean nothing you can't always
blame the home security system because
I'm [ __ ] my wife actually called me
dumb yesterday and she was right I tried
to put together this [ __ ] baby swing
and I'm like the [ __ ] it's a piece of
[ __ ] it's it's missing a part or
whatever you know and she ended up
figuring it out I thought she duct-taped
the thing so we got an arm ring
yesterday and she goes and you're
[ __ ] dumb okay you don't have the
patience to put something together you
know what when you get that mad yeah
high emotions of that high and then the
other person so [ __ ] right just how
dumb you feel well simply safe knows
that there's a lot of people like me in
the world so they designed a security
system that is not only secure it's so
easy that even a dope like me can use it
that is exactly the type of security
system simply safe to spend a decade
fighting against an overly difficult one
they that simply simple is safer and
it's exactly why simply safe is the home
security for right now when feeling safe
at home has never been more important
simply safe with designed to be easy
hey hey easy to use while protecting
your whole home 24/7 order online with
the click of a button open the box place
the sensors plug it in and your home is
protected around-the-clock look at that
[ __ ] I know it doesn't seem like even
needed a screwdriver order online with
the click of a button I don't know if I
can get past that but if I get past that
open the box place the sensors that's
perfect one if you can do that for your
kid you know sneaking out to do meth you
know you can put it on the [ __ ]
window
no technician or salesperson has to come
and disrupt your house you don't need to
pay any outrageous monthly fees or sign
a two-year contract tell a personal
story about setting up simply say for
about how simply safe it if possible
well you know what they already had a
ridiculously difficult home security
system in my place before I got my house
so you know my wife knows how to use it
all right can we stop exposing how dumb
I am simply safe was named Best Overall
home security of 2020 by US News and
World Report and there 24/7 professional
monitoring and emergency dispatch starts
at fifty cents a day head to simply
safecom slash / and get free shipping
and a 60-day money-back guarantee that
simply safe calm / / - make sure they
know that our show sent you all right
now with that let's get to some of your
questions for the week there shall we
come on come on why won't you go
backwards there we go there we go
here is the content alright here we go
here we go hey Bill okay celebrity
message video hey Billy would you're a
smart guy hey Billy he already has his
arm around me hey Mikey would you get
lost hey Billy would you're a smart guy
no I'm not and you've come up with a lot
of cool ideas if you were to produce a
celebrity video where they talk or sing
to the camera what would you I cannot
believe the amount of celebrities that
still do those videos no every
no matter what the [ __ ] message is
you're gonna get [ __ ] all over you know
and sometimes fans are right and other
times they just hate you because they
see how big your kitchen is you can't
win regular people really [ __ ]
annoyed me really annoy me with their
hypocrisy when they make fun of [ __ ]
celebrities and rather than seeing
themselves you know and all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] and they're like they think
that their lies aren't as bad as
celebrities lives because they have a
humble sized kitchen you're all the same
[ __ ] people
you just don't know how to act you know
maybe if you regular people learned how
to pretend a little better you could get
a bigger kitchen
if you can pretend to be somebody you're
not you can get a giant kitchen if you
were to produce a celebrity video where
they talk or sing to the camera what
would you do I wouldn't do it because I
know they'd all be yelling at me telling
me that I [ __ ] him over cuz you guys
would all trash him what song would you
all sing this is such a funny question
any celebrities of note that you would
have assuming you could have anyone and
Bill Moore most importantly what's the
message you want to get out there hugs
and kisses I would do a parody of it
because I lack the talent to execute it
you know to actually do a good one so I
would do a parody of it and I would
probably I would do it about
gold-digging [ __ ] or I would do it
about white women never feeling that
they were wrong or I would do it about
all the white women talking about white
women that they know who are actually
named Karen who are actually good people
watching white women trying desperately
not to be called on their [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know and not in and for
them not to be [ __ ] labeled is one of
my favorite things I've watched in a
while so I would probably do a video on
that and
I'm trying to think if there's a song
named Karen cuz they get this Oh Cheri
lady are we singing I'm the tab the guy
you know there's Ethel on my left how
funny is that wanderer song this Gladys
I'm in this flow um it's all old lady
names now but back then it's just like
flow was [ __ ] young and hot ah god
I'd love to get in her giant underpants
with all the [ __ ] frills on the back
knees a bogey boy he'd be a good boy of
hairy bushes let me see this there is
song named Karen Karen lyrics Karen I'm
not talking ID let's see videos I would
use this the first song I find Karen
song the new generator the new the Karen
new generation no I don't want it to be
Karen hip-hop let me just write Karen
love songs so I get an old-school one
love song alright Karen love song let's
see here if this was this this is
probably the one I would use after I get
past the advertising after I get past
the advertising okay skip the ad you
know people there are so many white
women out there named Karen
and they're not bad people
there's soccer moms there nurses I don't
think this is English they're white
women just like you and me dealing with
the toxic white males in their lives
[Music]
then I cut to a white woman named Karen
and she'd already be crying I mean I
know black people I mean African
Americans every really difficult in this
country and I know they're white police
officers have taken a lot of liberties
but just imagine what it's like to be
actually living with that white police
officer something like that I think
that's how it would go I don't know what
that [ __ ] that song was I don't know
when they go into a [ __ ] like if I
was a record producer and they were when
I was producing a song that [ __ ]
cheesy about some chick named Karen
Wright or a [ __ ] lady or whatever she
I would try to talk to the other
bandmates and be like hey guys is this
like a real chick does he really feel
this stuff or can we kind of [ __ ]
break balls as we record this knowing
that we're all just trying to make a
pile of cash and act like we're
sensitive people rather than we [ __ ]
everything that moves into a mountain of
cocaine during the recording and touring
of this album is this an actual Karen
and then the people the band be like we
don't know man he hasn't talked to us in
a while he teased on a separate tour bus
or they [ __ ] hate the lead singer so
much that they say no you know it isn't
a real woman and then I would say
something stupid about her and then
there'd be this big [ __ ] thing and
then I would get replaced and in would
walk Ted Templeman
all right new father bad relationship
dear bill what the [ __ ] do I do
oh wait are you asking me advice
oh [ __ ] it's time for me to play my
jingle where is it one of these days I'm
gonna get organized come on come on you
go there you go all right you have a
question I have a question people I will
give you an answer okay I will give you
I mean I don't have the answer but I'll
give you one do you want advice I'll say
something I will move my jaw and make
sounds in your directions
all right directions Direction all right
what the [ __ ] do what the he's like that
dude in platoon I got a bad feeling
my girlfriend keeps pressuring me into
marrying her we have a 7 month old baby
Jayde dude you are married for the next
20 [ __ ] years we have a 7 month old
baby girl together and I feel like if we
didn't have her we probably wouldn't be
together now my daughter is my world
wow-wow-wow from time to time I get hit
with this wave of [ __ ] I want to leave
her I do love her but I feel like we're
too much different from one another
her [ __ ] family is so involved
they're great but it's [ __ ] annoying
all right if you do love her and you do
have a kid at some point you got to put
your kid you know III don't know dude
I've never been in this situation thank
God but you know I would sit down you
gotta talk this out I mean I I would
talk to a therapist cuz the fact that
you still want to leave you got to
figure out why you do you want to leave
because you love her just because you
stayed with her long enough that you
love her like a friend or do you love
her lover but you already have a mr.
love a love you have a [ __ ] kid so I
would I would talk to a professional
about this but as far as the family you
just gotta set up some boundaries which
involves you really thinking about what
you want to say and then sit down and
have a talk
if somebody's you know crossing the line
there
we've been over the double line as they
say there the other day my girl was
bitching about her having to be at home
with the baby all the time well I work
six days a week in long hours well get
used to that pal it's always about them
she says that she feels like a slave I
know like you're out there [ __ ] yet
it's like I'm out there [ __ ] working
feeding all of you okay we had a kid
we bought do you think I want to work
six days a week I don't want to work six
days a week the way you don't want to
[ __ ] stay home the whole [ __ ] time
you know but trying to get them to
understand that that's that's that's a
that's a 90-degree [ __ ] grade Hill
which is a cliff buddy and it's got ice
on the face I'm like what the [ __ ] how
all you have to do is clean occasionally
and cook occasionally it's not like I'm
forcing her to clean and cook and take
care of [ __ ] sometimes she doesn't feel
like it and I don't care because I
understand she's feeling tired from
taking care of our baby alright so you
got some empathy there I I will tell you
having a baby I mean that's all
encompassing it's not like when they go
to sleep you have all this energy you
know you sleep when they sleep when I
move you move just like that Ludacris
when they sleep you sleep right
she also dude like a lot of things that
women say during this time you just
they're just overly tired they're overly
emotional you know what I mean their
hormones yeah whatever [ __ ] excuses
they have and what you have to do is you
your job is to push down that everything
that you're feeling okay and slowly inch
your way towards your first heart attack
at 58 oh I got some [ __ ] to say on this
one but let's let's just plow through
here then she says we're not even
married and I'm like what the [ __ ] does
that have to do with anything
it has to do with like her [ __ ] the
end of the price is right you know is
she gonna
win the showcase is she gonna get both
showcases she needs to know what's gonna
happen anyways I'm [ __ ] I [ __ ]
work and you take care of home seems
fair to me and I pay all the bills she
occasionally helps and is willing if I
ask but I prefer to take care of it yeah
that's it I'm earning money to keep the
lights on a food on the table and a roof
over our head and you're taking care of
the kid we're parents This Is It this is
this this [ __ ] bill of goods that
corporations sold women that you can
actually have it all which was is a lie
and they just wanted you to keep
spending and feeling like you needed
more I mean you guys are together and
you have a beautiful daughter and you
that's your world you don't need
anything else but what about that
Cuisinart like she gets to have fun all
she like she gets to have fun
still she gets to hang out with their
family go swimming or whatever you guys
have a pool that's [ __ ] amazing I can
never do [ __ ] because I have only one
day off and on my off day I [ __ ] run
errands oh Jesus - I know I know and
nobody cares and do whatever dumb [ __ ]
she wants to do this this is it dude
this is this is yeah this is welcome
this is being a dead this kind of
bitching occurs time to time and I'm and
I'm tired of it she's always bitching
saying I don't share a motion or spend
time with her well you're gonna have to
work on that these ways of just acting
like you're doing it and they'll believe
it just make an effort I'm the worst do
don't listen me if I'm not at work I'm
with her I even do the laundry alone at
the at the laundromat I wash dry and
fold while she stays home on my day off
okay but you have a pool but you don't
have a laundry so I think you have a
pool at your apartment or there's a town
pool she goes to but still a pool is the
[ __ ] I wash dry and if it's not yours
you know what to take care of it that's
even better I wash dry and fold while
she stays home on my day off she just
wants to [ __ ] she keeps pressuring me
to marry
and it keeps me and it makes me just
want to run but now that we have a baby
I'm scared that if we don't last how it
affect our daughter yeah you should be
thinking of your daughter first I'm not
even attracted to her the way I used to
be I don't know what to do well yeah I
mean if somebody's bitching at you all
the time you that [ __ ] tired you just
did they you fail to see who they were
this is something that could help you
guys is this someone in a really
involved family could watch the baby for
a day or two you take a day off from
work and you guys just get away and
maybe you know remember again why you
guys liked each other in the first place
because that's been great for me in my
life but I will tell you this this is
something that as a man you have to just
suck up and understand is that the
male-female relationship is all about
the woman all right that's what it is
and as much as they say they want to
hear from you and they want to know what
you're thinking it's it's about them
always them and their emotions comes
first it even it comes before the kids
you know that's how lets you know if
they're not happy no one gets to be
happy
there's no hey the kids are here that's
it's just how it [ __ ] you it's how
they're wired alright they can also make
a baby so there's there's that so you
got to focus on the positive but and
here's the thing as the guy you're gonna
be doing all of this [ __ ] working your
ass off you're gonna die before she does
and none of it is gonna be acknowledged
okay and if you want a little credit
you're being [ __ ] selfish okay and
that's basic I'm speaking in
generalities but that is essentially
what goes on there all right so you're
just gonna have to suck it up and
occasionally go out and get some beers
with other guys that you know who are
dads who are in the same situations and
you'll exchange stories and at first
you're gonna be a little pissed and then
you're just gonna start laughing it's
why guys are so fun
it's because of the situations that we
end up in and like having a kid is
really difficult and you know both
people's lives have to adjust because
you have the kid but one person it is
acknowledged you know it's constantly
acknowledged what a woman goes through
during pregnancy the importance of the
role of a mother in blah blah blah and
all it's up and been for guys it's
basically like a [ __ ] stick around
they need you alright don't be afraid to
do the laundry and cook and clean and
[ __ ] all of this other's [ __ ] so I
don't know I don't know what to tell you
buddy I would do what you need I think
you need to work on your relationship
and I'm not putting this on you but I
think you need to try to communicate to
her how you're feeling and this is a
very tricky thing because you could
marry her and she could become even more
of a [ __ ] nightmare or you could
marry her and that could have been the
issue and then she can [ __ ] settle
down because maybe she's getting
pressure from her family that you know
that they had a you know a kid he's she
had a kid out of wedlock
I don't know how religious Serpa it
might be that you know but I can tell
you this trying to make somebody else
happy is not something that you can do
it's impossible so what you have to do
is you know look out for yourself so I
would I would talk to a therapist about
what the [ __ ] is going on and I would
not marry her until you feel like that's
what you want to do okay and you know
when you sit down with her you can tell
her but the pressure that you're
underneath and I would stop short of
saying you know you bitching at me all
the [ __ ] time why the hell would I
marry you that's what you say to your
guy friend at the bar but as someone who
was [ __ ] had to be dragged kicking
and screaming I got married so late in
life I
I did it a lot younger and I loved being
married despite all this [ __ ] that I'm
saying there are certain things like
there's you know my wife would come on
here and do [ __ ] nine hours with no
guests about what a [ __ ] [ __ ] I am
to live with so I'm not trying to make
my way up out to be a bad guy I will
just say that in general nobody gives a
[ __ ] about the guy in the relationship
it's just what it is it's just how it is
it's just how it is
okay and you got to accept that for your
daughter okay and the fact that you had
it you have to man up you did have a kid
with this person and you need to do
everything you can do you know to make
sure that kid has the best childhood so
I would try the best I possibly can to
make this thing work which means you
have to try and communicate with you
know this woman about how you're feeling
and hopefully she's a cool chick and
will actually listen all right
rather than making everything about
herself and start [ __ ] crying and
then you're consoling her because she's
been a douche to you know boy all right
let's let's let's get off the subject
all right but I have tremendous amount
of issues with women so you know take it
all with a grain of salt but I would
talk to a professional rather than some
[ __ ] idiot all right
wild animal ride dear Billy bison Belt
loved you in the king of Staten Island
thank you so much for streaming the
movie if you could ride one wild animal
which would it be if I could ride one
people have rode ostriches [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that before see Swiss Family
Robinson from movie from the 1960s for
me
I'd love to ride a kangaroo or a panther
I would not want to ride a wild animal I
would I would want to ride a
domesticated broken animal like a pony
or a horse that is is sad and has
accepted the fact that a human being is
gonna get on its back you know just out
of my own personal safety so it won't
[ __ ] throw me head over heels and
then turn around and [ __ ] Maul me he
want to ride a panther I guess you
wouldn't get hurt in this scenario you
know what I'd like to do if it wouldn't
kill me I'd like to watch a ballgame
with the bear and have it sitting there
like a raccoon does when it's eating
Doritos on a couch some of those videos
we've seen just sit there with the
[ __ ] bear you know and there's a
[ __ ] call just [ __ ] both look at
each other and we both shake our heads
and we go back you know he's got a big
[ __ ] Sam and he's eating I'd be
smoking a stick you know what's funny
what I just pitched I could have sold
that as a movie when Clint Eastwood was
doing those orangutan movies deep it's
like Clint Eastwood makes Yogi Bear
every any which way you can all right
deep cuts hey Bill I am a female drummer
I love this person already and I know
you would totally be into this song high
noon from DJ shadows 1998 EP preemptive
strike in the heyday of my favorite era
of music mid-90s trip-hop this uk-based
artist releases are still inspiring
artists of today I think my wife listens
to him that's why I knew that I kind of
knew that name I should say known for a
dark blend of trippy beats moody
melodies and groundbreaking sampling
high noon is a rare instance where the
drum rhythm is the main focus and the
power powerful driver of the incredible
energy this song puts out it starts with
the bang and it's fast tempo culminates
in an absolutely climactic drum solo
that leaves you in a shudder of
goosebumps
it sounds like a movie review I gotta
listen to this people it's called high
noon from DJ shadows 1998 EP preemptive
strike you guys have really turned me on
to some great music by the way I
appreciate this features some of the my
favorite break beats of all time I've
never heard anything that even comes
close to it it's a thrill ride from
beginning to end to anyone who
appreciates drumming I watched this
whole thing on the history of hip-hop
what makes hip hop hip hop and I never
knew breakdancing was because when DJ's
would take that part of the song that
people wanted to listen to over and over
on a leap loop that became a break and
then these guys would dance to those
breaks became break dancers had no idea
I had no idea and I was young enough
when what was it electric Boogaloo and
all that [ __ ] came I had no idea what it
was we should just watch those [ __ ]
movies and laugh at the way they were
talking and dancing was just it was a
completely different world like you have
to understand there was no [ __ ]
internet and how advanced you know
dancing and all this [ __ ] was on the
inner city when it came out to us we
were just what the [ __ ] I was like what
was I mean was amazing but it was also
like watching a comedy because they were
speaking English we didn't understand
what the [ __ ] was going on deep cuts
hip-hop oh I love it here we go hello
mr. burr first of all I'm a huge fan of
you can I thank you very much thank you
very much thank you very much and as
you've been doing it as you've been
doing a music deep cut segment recently
I thought I would tell you about a few
hip-hop ones since I'm more familiar
with it rather than rock or heavy metal
The Punisher by Eric B and Rakim
released in 1992 this was on the fourth
and last album recorded by the Duke by
the duo Eric B and Rakim titled don't
sweat the technique the duo was
initially catapulted to fame by hit
singles Eric B is president released in
1986 what was the other one the other
one of the classic one that crossed over
I forget and
fantasy & rakim became incredibly famous
throughout New York City with records
such as paid-in-full that was the one I
knew I mean it's ridiculous just how
surface I am on so many different kinds
of music rap music country music and
follow the leader which displayed his
lyrical prowess The Punisher is another
one of these lyric lyrically dense songs
but seems to be overlooked by the other
hit songs from 1992 on both the east and
west coast wu-tang
vii chamber by wu-tang released in 1993
and included on their debut album
entered the wu-tang 36 chambers now this
I actually had this cassette tape and I
listened to this a zillion times when I
first moved to New York this song seems
to be overshadowed by such hits as cream
also known as cash rules everything
around me and Method Man is that the one
M ETH odigma
what was that from his single in
fairness the entire album is a
masterpiece so picking one song as the
bet I am I should know that one what
song is it a wu-tang by 7th Jam now this
one I should know let's see the thing no
one ever wanted to hear bill rapping
should i well this is a comedy contest
wu-tang the [ __ ] was it 7th chamber come
on people just just for once the
internet just [ __ ] work do I know
this one oh never
he always licks my [ __ ] alright hang on
a second
oh yeah I know it's one is he is he is
he dead
Vietnam I remember this alright alright
what if I'm gonna get in trouble with
these lyrics yeah I remember this one I
love this fight you know what this album
actually crossed over into my white
world I actually started listening to
this [ __ ] cuz by now I was hanging out
with Patrice this came out and was at 93
or something like that and I was hanging
out with Patrice and he had thrown all
my bad rap cassette tapes right out the
[ __ ] window and then told me what I
should be listening to and then when
this this one I actually I moved to New
York slightly before he did and people
were listening to this album and I was
in New York being like oh my god these
are racially mixed crowds I'm used to
just all-white angry people at [ __ ]
Knicks comedy stop what do I do so I was
like I need to listen to some of this we
I gotta get something in me so I need a
reference that can save me on a late
show something yeah so then I got the
tape and I I listened to that one what
did I listen to back then that was when
that came out the Fugees came out and
then there was the beginning of all that
biggie Tupac [ __ ] where they stopped
being friends and then all of that [ __ ]
happened right 93 by then dr. Dre and
Snoop Dogg all of that stuff came out I
was never into the West Coast [ __ ]
initially and then years later I'm
always I'm [ __ ] late to everything I
didn't get into grunge until like
[ __ ] the late 2000s on the worst
I'm the worst right all right
let's get back to the whatever the [ __ ]
I was just reading MMP content okay man
that brought back okay that one hut two
Hut 3 Hut ol Dirty Bastard live and
uncut a little stupid boombox
might walk through bedroom this song
seems to be alright alright okay there's
another one tres lay chase isn't it let
the [ __ ] cake Triborough trilogy by
Big Pun is that a cake am i [ __ ] crazy
this song is effectively now Big Pun I
knew the one dead in the middle of
Little Italy that that thing I knew that
one that he did with Fat Joe I'm a very
superficial guy I skim the top skim the
top I know I know just just enough to
get me through a comedy show late night
in New York City back in the day this
song is effectively a fusion of some of
the illest MCS in New York City 1998 off
the album capital punishment the Latino
rapper joins forces with prodigy of Mobb
Deep I remember a mob deep in this cat
this comedian James Talent Harris
telling me that because it was a guy you
ought the [ __ ] was honest John used to
go up I think he used to go on stage and
he was this old white dude is this old
white dude and he would go onstage and
he'd come on to someone of the mob deep
tracks and the crowd would always laugh
because they would hear that and they
would think it was gonna be some you
know gangsta you know black comic going
up there if that existed whatever or at
least that vibe and then this old white
guy would go up there and inspect a deck
from wu-tang clan all rapping on a be
produced by RZA also from the wu-tang
clan all three rappers showcase their
talent exquisitely and it's almost
strange this song is not as popular as
others released by Big Pun the raw vinyl
records scratching sound along with the
skillful technique makes this track a
must listen here's a list of some songs
which I think are a bit obscure overall
all of these songs are incredible and I
feel people who are into hip-hop or get
into it should listen to these joints to
get the full experience I love that he
didn't adjust his slang so you could
hear me say these joints all right here
we go as the rhythm goes Eric B and
Rakim passed the hand grenade
Eric B and Ricky Eric being Rakim Rakim
am I saying the right anger in the
nation Pete Rock something a white guy
and CL Smooth come clean Giroux the oh
my god I'm just gonna get [ __ ] made
fun of here
da Maj a distortion to static the roots
all we got is us onyx uncut raw AZ
literally like Arizona abbreviation
music makes me high Lost Boys open
minded ghetto ghetto boys assassination
day go space killer Inspectah deck
raquan RZA section the roots nighttime
vultures mobb deep featuring raquan G
that guy got around huh New York yeah
out there Brooke him lie to kick it to
puck as high as whoo tang get obviously
wu-tang clan this guy's got a bunch of
severe punishment wu-tang clan the worst
onyx it's a must we're Kim featuring our
aah GTL we ain't the game featuring mmm
Cinderella man mmm legacy Eminem you
know what there was an Eminem one that
he had a guy on there he did a guest
spot and I thought he was [ __ ] amazing
and then I never saw him do anything
else or maybe I just didn't search it
with the father to figure that one out
so there you go for all you white people
out there I want to have a cooler [ __ ]
music list there's some deep cuts some
deep cuts off some joints from some
rappers sorry all right where are we
here our and 6 minutes in there we go
people how about that that wasn't bad no
news no news no news
I didn't I stayed out of the [ __ ]
quagmire
I had to give the racist orange [ __ ] a
little bit of [ __ ] they gotta get that
Mike Pence yeah Mike Pence needs to
accidentally push that guy down the
[ __ ] stairs and then Mike Pence did
[ __ ] run then we can just go back to
[ __ ] normal all right
we'll go back to normal with a couple of
old white guys running for president
strange times alright
anyways that's the podcast everybody
please watch season four of f is for
family
please Stream the king of Staten Island
and or listen all this cool old deep cut
hip-hop [ __ ] that I just this person let
us know about and also high noon DJ
shadow 1998 alright that is it go [ __ ]
yourselves I will talk to you I'll check
in on Thursday stop